the iPhone 15 lineup finally has USBC
which means it just got access to a
bunch of fun new accessories enabling
you to do things that have never been
possible in the history of the iPhone so
in this video I'm going to go through 15
of my personal favorite cool and unique
accessories with links to all of them
down in the description below so let's
get started with the first one which is
this right here which is perfect perfect
for the iPhone 15's USBC Port this is
pitaka's power dongle which is basically
a 5w fast charger for your Apple watch
but now that we have USBC on the iPhone
15s you can simply plug it in to create
the smallest Apple watch charger
possible charging straight from your
iPhone check this out it's literally
charging you see that right there it's
pulling 4.5 WTS from the iPhone 15 Pro
which is how much that can put out which
is basically fast enough to charge it
very quickly wherever you are anywhere
literally just grab this with you put it
in your travel bag or anywhere it's tiny
and you always have an Apple Watch
charger with you which is the iPhone 15
for number two we have this my keys well
not just my keys but this right here
which is no nad's charge key it's
basically a very small USBC cable as you
can see this tiny little thing on my
keychain it's magnetic so the pieces
hold together like this USBC to USBC so
you basically always have an emergency
charging cable no matter where you go
it's always on your key so basically
here you go plug it into one iPhone and
let's plug it into another and there you
go we're charging another iPhone 15
using my literal keychain right here
I've actually used it already to
transfer videos from my iPhone to my Mac
and you can basically use it for any
other USBC device not just for your
iPhone and this charge key also comes in
USBC to lightning as well if you haven't
upgraded to an iPhone 15 now moving on
to number three we have this thing right
here which is the Razor phone cooler and
the best part is that it's supports Mac
safe so there you go snap it onto the
back of your iPhone it holds just like
that but even better the iPhone can
actually power this cooler and the best
part is that this actually uses a
Peltier cooling block and fan system so
I've actually tested the temp on the
back it gets ice cold I literally Saw It
Go as low as 3 de C that's almost
freezing and it's powered by the iPhone
itself I actually ran a 40-minute stress
test with 3D Marks Wildlife extreme
Benchmark and I ran it both with and
without the cooler after 40 minutes the
cooler helped the score of the final
40th Loop of The Benchmark improve by
12% yes 12% that's even more than
Apple's 10% single core CPU improvement
with the new a17 Pro chip and I know
some of you guys are going to laugh at
this but it actually is very helpful the
main reason you're going to use it is
that if you're outside kind of in the
Heat and your phone's getting hot while
playing games it's going to help stop
the display from dimming and the phone
from overheating it's essentially fully
going to stop thermal throttling from
the heat soaking of the chassis because
if the actual iPhone chassis overheats
it's going to Throttle Down your chip
and this thing is going to stop that and
speaking of gaming let's get into number
four which is this this Apple's
multi-port USBC adapter it supports 4K
60fps so I actually bought this myself
and used it to play games on my 4K 150
in projector at home at 60 FPS I
basically used it I plugged it into the
iPhone then I used it to power the Razer
phone cooler I passed through charged
the iPhone and I had HDMI connected to
my projector basically creating the
perfect perf gaming console setup for
when AAA games come later this fall the
ones that Apple revealed but I'd
honestly say that number five is
actually a better value than this
because it is pretty expensive you know
you're paying for the Apple quality and
reliability but you also have this from
basis which is a 13 in1 USBC Hub we
tested this out when we first got the 15
Pro Max we plugged in multiple SD cards
multiple accessories and and
surprisingly everything worked it also
supports ethernet display port a couple
of hdmis pass through charging and
headphone jack as well so it's fully
loaded if you want to plug in a ton of
stuff into your iPhone 15 this is a
really really great value and so much
functionality add it to this next up we
have this super unique case from our
sponsor magb which not only supports Mac
safe charging but it actually has extra
magnets on the inside so you can mount
your iPhone to any metal surface or use
it with the included Mac stick for
mounting it on your car's dashboard or
anywhere else there's also the magb
wallet which has the strongest magnetic
connection ever thanks to the extra
magnets inside of the case with dual
pockets for cards and cash as well as a
finger Loop and you can buy both of them
using the link below and code maxtech 15
for 15% off moving on we have this thing
right here which is satki USBC to SD
card adapter which also has a Micro SD
card slot as well this thing right here
is very convenient because you can plug
it into your iPhone 15 Pro and check
this out you turn on prores and
instantly you can see the little USBC
text right there at the bottom which
means that it's going to be recording
video directly to the s d card and the
nice thing about this sateki adapter is
that the cable is long enough for you to
put some sticky tape on the back of this
and stick it right onto your iPhone and
you can just walk around recording
everything directly to the SD card and
when you're done simply unplug it and
take this to your Mac plug it in
transfer everything very quickly which
is why I recommend having a very fast SD
card as well and I'm going to leave the
link down in the description below next
up we have the these really cool
magnetic cables from maame as you can
see they coil up they're fully magnetic
they attached to each other they have
their o variant which is round like this
or they have this flat style that can
easily roll up into a nice Circle and
the Really convenient thing is that you
could actually wound up a really tight
Circle if you want so that you could
stick it into your briefcase or your
travel bag and even better you can
actually wind up 2K cables together like
this if you have two accessories you
want to charge so let's say your iPhone
and another iPhone or anything else you
could actually coil them up and have
them attach this is definitely one of
the coolest cables because it's going to
stop it from tangling from fraying and
ripping like a lot of cables do this is
going to solve that problem keeping it
nice and organized and the braiding is
really nice as well and they have tons
of variants they have USB a to c they
have C to C and of course they also have
usba a to lightning and USB C to
lightning as well moving on we have this
thing right here from Anker this is
anker's Gan Prime portable charger but
it's not like any other portable battery
Bank out there because it has this
prongs for a wall outlet so basically
whenever you're at home or in the office
you plug it into the wall you can use
these ports right here to charge your
iPhone but then when you have to leave
you could actually take it out of the
wall and it has battery inside of it so
it's going to continue to charge take it
anywhere you want and then when you get
home again plug it in it's going to top
it off so it's fully ready for when you
have to leave again this is definitely a
genius idea and just to prove it to you
guys there you go you can see that it's
charging while not being plugged into
the wall at all but if you want to go
all out we have this right here which is
the sh geek one 70 which basically
supplies an insane
170 wats total of power so you can
charge your iPhone and you can give 140
watts of charging to your 16in MacBook
Pro now I know there's a lot of portable
battery packs out there but I haven't
seen many that actually hit 170 wats
total and of course it also has this
display that will show you the total
output power in terms of wattage and
input charging power and the remaining
percentage as well now let's step away
from charging for a second because I
want to show you guys this right here
which is the mof mag safe wallet I've
actually been using this for the last
couple of years I have a brown model as
you can see it's definitely a little bit
worn I have my cards in here right now
you can see that I've definitely been
putting it to use because you can see it
kind of fraying and ripping right here
but
these new ones are amazing because they
have a new moas leather material which
is actually stronger and it feels nicer
but the nice thing is that they've
upgraded the magnets making them much
stronger this year you can use it as a
mount for your iPhone like this you can
set it down like that and you can also
put it into this nice floating mode as
you can see just like that I strongly
recommend it to anybody looking for a
Mac safe wallet and now with moving on
we have this right here I'm just kidding
I don't have it in my hand because it's
actually in my car right now it's esrs
cryoboost car charger which supports
full official 15w Max safe charging for
your iPhone with a fan cooler buil in
which actually makes sure that it
doesn't overheat and cause the display
to D when you're using location GPS
services for navigation making it really
hard to see it basically keeps it cool
stops it from thermal throttling so that
it charges much faster next up we have
this right here which is the insta 360
flow Gimbal and I believe it's the best
gimbal out there because when you unfold
it like this it basically opens up right
away and turns on which is actually
really really cool you have multiple
different buttons including a record
button I can instantly put it into
landscape mode just like this double tap
on that button look at that this is
really really cool this is by far the
best coolest gimbal you can find and
then when you're done simply fold it in
like this and there you go it kind of
folds down and shuts off and then moving
on we have this right here which is
span's easy fit screen protector which
is glass and the reason it's my favorite
is because it has this plastic case that
basically creates the easiest
installation process ever it has a slot
in the Middle where you basically put it
over your phone use your finger to apply
pressure in a swiping motion wait 30
seconds take it off get rid of the
bubbles you are done by far the best
screen protector I could find and then
finally we have this thing right here
from ESR it's their 100 wat 6 in1
charging stand and this is by far my
favorite charging stand of all time that
I actually use in the office next to my
Mac every single day and I would argue
that this is perfect for anybody out
there with their own office or at home
maybe in your living room on the side
table this is great because it offers
official full 15w Max safe charging for
your iPhone with cryo boost technology
as well so it has a fan to help cool it
down to make it charge faster and it has
official 5 wat Apple watch fast charging
as well which is the fastest charging
speed that you can get and on top of
that it has a pad for your airpods has a
button right here if you want to turn
off the lights at night so it's not
distracting but here is the final kicker
on the side you have three extra ports
one usba a and you also have two USBC
ports that both can go up to 100 watts
of power and the best part is that the
entire power supply is actually built
into this block section in the charging
stand itself so on the other end you
have a simple wall plug with no power
adapter brick laying around on the floor
this is by far the best implementation
of a charging stand I could find so
there you guys go those were the top 15
accessories my personal favorites and
you can find the links down in the
description below so don't miss those
definitely check out the mag back case
from our sponsor click that Circle
button to subscribe and definitely check
out one of those two videos right over
there thanks for watching and we'll see
you in the next
[Music]
video